President Trump faces off with Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer in the Oval
Office google goes to the hill and
another terror attack rocks France I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
a lot of fun to be had with today's news
we will get to it in just one second
first let's talk about how you can relax
this holiday season perhaps you've been
running ragged at work perhaps the kids
are driving you nuts perhaps you're just
stressed out or you have back pain well
one of the things you can do to make
yourself really feel wealthy this
holiday season without expending
enormous sums of cash is to go check out
Zeile Zeile is the Android iPhone app
and it allows you to get a massage on
demand in your home from a licensed
masseuse just go to Zeile calm or zeals
iPhone or Android app that is Zeile ze e
Elcom select from top local licensed
pre-screened massage therapists choose
your favorite technique gender
preference time and location for your
massage deal will then send one of their
10,000 licensed massage therapists with
a massage table music and supplies to
give you a five-star massage scheduling
booking payment fast and easy even the
tip is included 7 days a week 365 days a
year
Azul massage therapist can be at your
door and as little as an hour privacy
convenience quality and comfort that's
what you get with your massage on demand
with zeal how good is heal it's so good
that I have used it my wife has used it
my parents have used it my in-laws have
used it and my sisters have used it it
is that good go check it out
right now bring the spa to you you don't
have to wait in line at the spa or pay
exorbitant sums of money and make a date
and time with them they come to you
instead to help you get started our
listeners get 25 bucks off their first
massage when you use promo code Ben
that's zeals EEE Elcom promo code Ben
right now go to zeal comm again or that
CLI phone or Android app get a special
offer when you try seal today use promo
code Ben get 25 bucks off your first
in-home massage it really is a fantastic
thing a luxury item that doesn't feel
like you're paying luxury prices zeal
calm and use that promo code been 425
bucks off okay so the big news yesterday
obviously was that president from face
down Nancy Pelosi instruction were in
the Oval Office
now I'm not a fan of these sorts of
meetings I don't know for example why
President Trump if he wanted to meet
with the leadership of the incoming
Congress didn't meet with Nancy Pelosi
and Mitch McConnell why he met with
Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
you know Chuck Schumer doesn't have tons
of power in the Senate considering that
he is still in the minority
with that said the President did
something smart President Trump did
something very smart he said we are
going to negotiate in front of these
cameras and Nancy Pelosi did not want to
negotiate in front of the cameras
I choose she was upset about this she
said in front of Trump I don't want to
negotiate in front of the cameras it
would just be terrible and Trump's like
I don't care we're doing this thing and
then they just went at each other and
that was good for President Trump I
think so president Trump did some good
things and some bad things I mean this
was case study in good Trump bad Trump
President Trump did some good things and
some bad things the good thing that he
did was he forced the Democrats to
defend their position that they would
never fund a border wall but they would
not fund border security and that in
fact they'd be willing to shut down the
government in order to prevent funding
for border security because it's pretty
much the only thing Democrats don't want
to spend money on they want to spend
money on federal sponsorship for lesbian
dance theory in college but they don't
want to spend money on supporting our
southern border needs right so President
Trump making them say that in front of
the cameras is a very good thing a not
so good thing is when the president then
says well you know what I'll be blamed
for the shutdown fine do it okay the
reason being not that Republicans should
fear a shutdown I think the Republicans
have always been far too afraid of a
shutdown I don't like it when Republican
politicians say things like all
government shutdown would just be so
terrible why we've had several of them
has anyone died have people been Keeling
over in the streets was there a zombie
apocalypse was it like Shaun of the Dead
none of that happened okay it wasn't 21
days later it wasn't it wasn't people
just wandering the streets didn't
bloodless cannibalizing one another
wasn't the purge when there was a
government shutdown all that happened is
that a few non-essential government
employees didn't go to work that day by
the way if you're a non-essential
government employee I would suggest that
perhaps you shouldn't be working in the
government all the employees at the
Daily wire are essential congratulations
guys are all essential but if you are
not if you're if you were a
non-essential employee of The Daily wire
you would not be working here I don't
understand why we have non-essential
employees of the federal government in
the first place I whenever there's a
government shutdown we are told by the
press by the Democrats end of the world
people will die not true mandatory
government spending continues as central
government employees in the Social
Security office and Medicaid office all
those folks continue to work it just
curbs some of the activities around the
fringes so Republicans should not be so
fearful little government shutdown and
I've always been
kepta chol of republicans who say well
you know we really have to avoid the
government shutting out what that said
your preferred strategy is this if
you're a Republican if there's an issue
that you really care about like border
security it is I want my budget to have
border security funding in it and I'm
not signing a budget this does not have
border security funding in it and if you
are willing to shut down the government
by not sending me a budget with what I
want in it well then that's your fault
because you're now responsible for
people not being able to go to work
today because you wouldn't give me the
funding necessary in order to secure our
southern border so the trouble the
shutdown is your fault but if it has to
shut down because you're not gonna fund
me well then I guess that's your choice
right that's the way you play this
president Trump gets part of it and he
doesn't get part of it so President
Trump gets the part where he says listen
I'm willing to not sign a budget if he
doesn't have what I want but then he
goes further he says and you know what
I'll own the shutdown I'll say it's my
fault
why would you do this what is the logic
behind doing this right I told you the
good Trump is him facing down Pelosi and
Schumer we'll show you that in a second
but he starts off by saying now I'll own
it fine you want to say that it's my
fault the government's shutting down
okay why why would you do that it's not
in fact his fault if the government
shuts down it's the Democrats fault for
not passing a budget that he wants
problem is that you know when the when
we glass slows down that was his idea
and honestly he got killed and so he
doesn't want to own it and I said you
know what rather than us debating who's
owning it I'll take it I'll take it if
we close down the country I will take it
because we're closing it down for border
security and I think I win that every
single time okay so I'm not sure that he
wins it every single time but I mean his
own logic president from some logic
suggests that you know it'd be great if
Chuck Schumer got blamed for the
government shutdown
he just says Chuck Schumer tried to shut
down the government in order to get
funding for his priorities and then he
got blamed for it and it was a real bad
move by Chuck Schumer why would you not
just repeat this why not just make Chuck
Schumer do it again
instead president Trump because he feels
the necessity to jump on every grenade
says no I own it
I want it just like I own it I'll put a
big Trump Tower sign insignia on it um
plated in gold next to my toilet it'll
be unbelievable again President Trump is
correct to say I'm not gonna sign a
budget without border funding he is not
correct
to say I'm gonna own the shutdown that
would be the fault of the Democrats well
Chuck Schumer then responded and he got
very upset because President Trump and
Schumer really went at it in the Oval
Office and at a certain point during the
conversation president Trump Lente's go
to which as I won deal with it and Chuck
Schumer responded by saying well when
you're in trouble you just brag Nancy
we've gained into Senate excuse me did
we win the Senate when the president
brags that he won North Dakota and
Indiana he's in real trouble I did we
did win they got very contentious by the
way Trump isn't wrong there Chuck
Schumer did a poor enough job in the
Senate that his side lost seats in an
election a wave election in which they
won the house vote by eight point six
percent so you know President Trump says
and this is where he's good he says I
won't take a deal without border
security like if you're gonna give me a
deal and doesn't have border security
guess what not happening we have a
proposal that Democrats and Republicans
will support to do a CR that will not
shut down the government we urge you to
take it if it's not good border security
is very good okay well Trump is exactly
right on this so again I think that
Trump negotiating in front of the
cameras is very often his best stuff
because he looks strong and makes him
look tough and he was being tough with
Chuck Schumer a lot of the
back-and-forth had to do with Nancy
Pelosi saying well if you you guys run
the house you guys run the Senate why
don't you just pass a budget that you
guys want and Trump saying well I don't
have sixty votes in the Senate and
Pelosi saying well you could at least
vote in the house and Trump going I
don't have sixty votes in the Senate and
Trump of course was right about all of
this you could see who sort of won this
showdown at least in the public mind or
at least in public eye by how the
Democrats reacted to this a Nancy Pelosi
after this whole hubbub she went out to
the press and she was basically whining
that had gone poorly for her and she was
she was doing her routine from Seinfeld
the jerk store routine where she was
insults and then she thought of a
comeback 30 minutes after the insult
battle ended here was Nancy Pelosi
saying well you know I'm just so nice
and kind I didn't want to tell President
Trump that he didn't know what he was
talking about wow there were cameras
there so now I'll tell all the cameras
well he's not here but he didn't know
what he was talking about we don't want
to contradict the president when he was
putting forth figures
that had no reality to them no basis in
fact we have to have regard to proceed
in all of this have evidence-based
factual truthful information about what
works and what doesn't I didn't want to
in front of those people say you don't
know what you're talking about
so I'll just say in front of you the
press love it I love the casual
dishonesty of the Democrats saying well
no I just didn't want to say it in front
of the reason she didn't want to say it
in front of Trump is because Trump would
have whomped her because President Trump
was not going to sit there and take it
again President Trump in confrontational
situations is at his best when those
confrontations are about politics and
president Trump's aggression in
situations like this is actually quite a
good thing now does it necessarily feel
good to a lot of establishment
Republicans no but this is why a lot of
president Trump's base likes President
Trump is because if Nancy Pelosi sits
there and fibs about border security or
if Chuck Schumer sits there and says I
don't want to talk about this stuff
publicly and Trump says we're going to
talk about it publicly you know that's
that's good for Trump I think it's good
for Republicans again I don't think you
should say you own the shutdown and give
Democrats the headline but still I don't
think this went poorly for President
Trump by any stretch again Nancy Pelosi
looked very angry and very upset after
this meeting she says that she told
Trump to pray for biblical wisdom always
a great injunction from a woman who
believes that children should be killed
in the womb I myself thought we would
have open the meeting with a prayer and
I told him about Solomon King Solomon
when he became when he was to become
King of the Jews he he he prayed to God
he said how can I ever follow King David
King David King of the Jews
I need you to give me a great
understanding and wisdom Lord and after
he prayed and prayed and prayed God came
to me and said Solomon because you did
not ask for longevity great wealth or
vengeance against your enemies I will
give you more wisdom than anyone has
ever had the wisdom of Solomon okay so I
don't know how she's paraphrasing Bible
here but in any case I'm sort of shocked
that she didn't actually I'm shocked she
didn't actually quote the the section of
the of the Bible in which Solomon says
that he might split a baby
because that seems actually more alive
if Nancy Pelosi's general political
viewpoint I love it when when people who
are super pro-abortion
are quoting the Bible at people like
President Trump is just it's delightful
Pelosi and Schumer finish off by saying
that President Trump threw a temper
tantrum in the Oval Office and they
called it the Trump shutdown and this is
where Trump's mistake starts to take
root as you're going to hear from now
until the end of whatever happens here
from the press that this is the Trump
shutdown again Trump didn't have to own
it that was a mistake by President Trump
this Trump shutdown this temper tantrum
that he seems to throw will not get him
his wall and it'll hurt a lot of people
because he will cause a shutdown he
admitted he wanted a shutdown it's hard
to believe that he would want that that
the president choose to shut down the
government that we have a trump shut
down as a Christmas present a holiday
present to the American people well
they're on branding they're on branding
I mean this is this is their routine so
when it was Congress it was Ted Cruz's
fault when the government shutdown in
2013 because he was in Congress now it's
president Trump's fault that the shut
that the government is shutting down
when he's not in Congress weird how the
media always tried to spin it as a
Republican shutdown of the government
even when Democrats are pretty obviously
shutting down the government again
President Trump did not help here
particularly a lot we're gonna get to
Nancy Pelosi's final shots at President
Trump in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that at some point
in the future hopefully a long time from
today you're gonna plot you're gonna
occupy that mahogany condo and you want
to make sure that your family is insured
you want to make sure that your family
has the money to take care of themselves
that they're not gonna simply bury you
in a pauper's grave like Mozart that
you're not going to be lost to the
history that you can buy yourself a
really nice mausoleum and the whole
thing you wanna make sure that you got
all those things and life insurance can
make sure you have all of those things
but you don't want to think about death
or life insurance which is why you ought
to go to policy genius right now it's
the easy way to get life insurance in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find the coverage you need
at a price you can afford from there you
can apply online and the unbiased
advisors a policy genius will handle all
the red tape leaving you free to do the
things you actually enjoy doing policy
genius doesn't just make life insurance
easy whether you're shopping for
disability insurance to protect your
income or homeowners insurance or auto
insurance they can help you get covered
fast if you've been intimidated or
frustrated by insurance in the past give
policy genius a try just go to policy
genius.com right now get your quotes
apply in minutes you can do the whole
thing on your phone
right now you can pause the show if
it'll sing the podcast and you just
pause it go to policy genius get your
wife insurance taken care of and feel
good about yourself policy genius is the
easy way to compare and buy life
insurance go check it out right now
policy genius.com nancy pelosi concluded
the negotiations with President Trump by
going back to her Democratic caucus and
then talking about president Trump's
manhood these people are all civility
and all class she said it's like a
manhood thing with him as if manhood can
be associated with him and then she set
up the conversation with Trump it goes
to show you you can get into a tinkle
contest with a skunk you get tinkle all
over you that's some weird verbiage a
tinkle contests with a skunk
you get tinkle all over you well I guess
when you are 1,000 years old this is the
kind of language that you use to
describe a political club fight in the
Oval Office and here's the point
Democrats don't want to find president
Trump's priorities on the border the
reason the question we should be asking
ourselves is why do they not actually
want to be funding these border
priorities we're not talking about a lot
of money we're not talking about a great
deal of expenditure we're not talking
about something impossible or crazy it
is not impossible or crazy to ensure
that our border is secure President
Trump is talking about five billion
dollars I mean the government spends
that about every five seconds the fact
that Democrats are trying to suddenly
skimp on border security should be
telling you something about their actual
priorities and I think president from
knows that which is why President Trump
is pushing on this particular subject
and pushing very hard on this particular
subject I don't think he's wrong to do
it and I think that now that he's got
Democrats in the majority in the house
at least incoming he has the ability to
to at least cast aspersions that their
willingness to protect our southern
border which should be of serious
concern it should be of serious concern
who crosses that border apparently we've
been arresting thousands of people every
day crossing that border securing the
border seems like a no-brainer Trump
knows it the American people are in
favor of it and the fact that Democrats
are willing to let people go unemployed
for the holidays because they won't fund
a border wall is pretty astonishing that
said President Trump you know should
have done this when there was a
Republican Congress and it is kind of
devastating that he didn't okay in just
a second I want to get to the
latest developments in the Muller
investigation and in the Michael Flynn
pleading so here's the latest with
regard to all of the various Trump legal
developments so according to Hans van
szpakowski Hans von Spakovsky sorry over
at the daily signal Heritage Foundation
he talks about the possibility the
president Trump will be indicted so this
entire week a lot of last week thanks to
Michael cones plea agreement and thanks
to the Southern District of New York's
sentencing memo there's been a lot of
talk the President of the United States
is gonna be indicted for a campaign
finance violation Hans von Spakovsky
makes the case that President Trump
cannot be indicted for campaign finance
violation because Michael Cohen didn't
actually commit a campaign finance a
violation here's what szpakowski says he
says in fact neither the Federal
Election Commission which is independent
agency tasked with enforcing the federal
election campaign Act nor its former
commissioners would likely agree with
the over-aggressive view that the
southern district is taking indeed the
southern districts aggressive stance on
this issue might have violated the
Justice Department's own policy why well
the initial claim is that Michael Cohen
used money from his pockets payoff
stormy Daniels and was reimbursed by
President Trump in order to avoid
disclosure issues in campaign finance
that basically this was an in-kind
contribution to President Trump in the
amount of a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars that was never reported to the
FEC
and surpassed all campaign finance
limits but Robert Kazami was the acting
US Attorney standing in for Jeffrey
Berman who's recused himself from the
Cohen case says in the government's
sentencing memo that Cohen committed a
campaign finance violation by arranging
payments from corporations to two woman
women one and woman two that became
mcdougal and stormy Daniels who claimed
they had affairs with Trump in order to
buy their silence Cohn eventually
invoiced the Trump Organization for the
Daniels payment whose ami asserts that
these were illegal corporate
contributions to the Trump campaign
because they were made with the intent
to influence the 2016 presidential
election but there are a lot of problems
with this claim first his theory that
anything intended to influence an
election is a campaign related expense
fails to take into account the statutes
wearing limitation on this definition
according to federal election elections
law it specifically says that campaign
related expenses do not include any
expenditures used to fulfill any
commitment obligation or expense of a
person that would exist irrespective of
the candidates election campaign these
payments were relatively small given
Trump's net worth the kind of nuisance
settlement celebrities often
to protect their reputations given Trump
celebrity status the potential liability
to these women existed irrespective of
the president's election campaign this
is the case that I've made is that Trump
has been paying off women for years this
is just the latest example of a woman
being paid off
unlike store McDaniels and Karen
McDougal in the John Edwards case real
hunter whose Edwards mistress was paid a
million bucks
while directly working for the campaign
and John Edwards her payments did not go
through the Edward campaign's account
but the government tried to claim there
were campaign expenditures because they
were intended to protect Edwards his
reputations or in his presidential run
and thus influence the election but a
jury acquitted Edwards on the charge of
accepting an illegal campaign donation
and failed to reach a verdict on the
other charges the fact that a jury
didn't convict Edwards wouldn't
ordinarily mean the government didn't
have a viable claim but Edwards had two
former chairman of the FEC on retainer
who are prepared to testify that such
payments to a mistress are not actually
campaign related expenses so this is the
affirmative case being made by Hans von
Spakovsky as to why President Trump
cannot actually be prosecuted in terms
of violation of campaign finance now in
other President Trump
legal news the incoming New York
Attorney General has now said that she
is interested in prosecuting any and all
members of the Trump family and this is
pretty incredible stuff it's pretty
obvious at this point that law
enforcement mechanisms are being used to
target specific people as Ari Fleischer
pointed out on Twitter and he's exactly
correct the former bush press secretary
the way that law enforcement is supposed
to work is you identify a crime and then
you identify the person responsible for
the crime and then you prosecute the
person responsible for the crime but now
it appears that the prosecutor the
Attorney General elected in New York is
saying that she's going to identify the
person and then identify the crime this
would be the definition of selective
prosecution New York Attorney General
Alexis James says she plans to launch
sweeping investigations into President
Donald Trump his family and anyone in
his circle who may have violated the law
once she settles into her new job next
month she said will use every area of
the law to investigate President Trump
and his business transactions and that
of his family as well she of course is a
Democrat and she told NBC News in her
first extensive interview since she was
elected last month that she intends on
targeting Trump and his family this
would include involve this would include
investigating any potential illegalities
involving president Trump's real estate
holdings in New York the June 2016 Trump
Tower meeting with a Russian official
government subsidies
by President Trump well there he's in
violation of the emoluments clause in
the US Constitution continuing to probe
the Trump Foundation and supposedly
legalities and their handling of their
501 C 3 James says we want to
investigate anyone in his orbit who has
in fact violated the law this is pretty
astonishing stuff to openly say that you
are taking on a specific human as
opposed to a specific crime that is a
basic violation of prosecutorial duty
James said taking on President Trump and
looking at all the violations of law I
think is no match to what I have seen in
my lifetime and this is if you're
wondering why so many Republicans feel
that the justice system looks like it's
being used as a tool against President
Trump statements like that certainly
have something to do with it I'm gonna
explain more about the use of the
justice system against certain Trump
officials in just one second first let's
talk about how you're sending your
packages this Christmas I know you're
gonna be sending out enormous numbers of
gifts to family and friends it's gonna
cost you a fortune just to drive that
stuff over to the post office and you
have to stand in line with all of these
gifts and these boxes and the whole
spiel instead mind just do it from home
with stamps calm it brings all the great
services of the US postal office
directly to your desktop you can buy and
print official US postage for any letter
any package any class of mail using your
own computer and printer and then the
mail carrier picks it up no trips to the
post office required could not be easier
to print postage any day any time stamps
calm is always open and not only to
stamps calm save you time it saves you
money because stamps calm helps you
print the right amount of postage every
time so you never overpay again and you
get discounts on postage you can't even
get at the post office we use stamps
calm here at the Daily wire offices it
saves us time it saves us money
stamps calm is a great gift you can give
yourself this holiday season right now
you can get a special deal with stamps
calm that includes a four week trial
plus postage and the digital scale
without long term commitments doesn't
get much better than that go to stamps
calm click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in promo code
Shapiro that is stamps calm again enter
promo code Shapiro and when you do so
you will get that special deal a four
week trial plus postage and the digital
scale without long term commitments go
check it out right now stamps comm again
use that promo code Shapiro for the
special deal the services of the post
offices direct at your fingertips just
fantastic stuff go check it out right
now stamps comm promo code Shapiro okay
meanwhile the FBI I
there's a new memo out that shows that
the FBI recommended the Michael Flynn
who you will recall was prosecuted by
the Department of Justice that he not
have a lawyer present
during his interview and did not warn
him that his statement would have
consequences so according to a memo from
former FBI director deputy director
Andrew McCabe the interview that
ultimately led to Michael Flynn's guilty
plea on one count of making false
statements this is where Michael Flynn
said he had not talked with the Russians
during the transition suggested that
Flynn not have a lawyer present at the
session according to newly filed court
documents in addition FBI officials
along with the two agents who
interviewed Flynn decided specifically
not to warn him that there would be
penalties for making false statements
because the agents wanted to ensure that
Flynn was relaxed during the session the
new information was drawn from McCabe's
account of events plus FBI agents right
ups of the interview the so-called 3:02
report it's contained in a sentencing
memo filed Tuesday by Flynn's defense
team citing McCabe's accounts the
sentencing memo says that shortly after
noon on January 24th the fourth day of
the new Trump administration McCabe
called Flynn on a secure phone influence
West Wing office
the two men discussed business briefly
and then McCabe said he felt that we
needed to have two of our agents sit
down with Flynn to discuss Flynn's
talked with Russian officials during the
presidential transition McCabe by his
own account urged Flynn to talk to the
agents alone without a lawyer present I
explained I thought the quickest way to
get this done was to have a conversation
between Flynn and the agents only said
McCabe I further stated that lieutenant
general Flynn wished to include anyone
else in the meeting like the White House
Counsel for instance that I would need
to involve the Department of Justice
Flynn stated this would not be necessary
and agreed to meet with the agents
without any additional participants
within two hours the agents were in
Flynn's office according to the 302
report quoted in Flynn's sentencing
document the agent said Flynn was
relaxed and jocular and offered the
agents a little tour of his part of the
White House the agents did not provide
general Flynn with a warning of the
penalties for making false statements
under 18 US Code 1001 for during her
after the interview according to the
Flynn memo according to the 302 before
the interview McCabe and other FBI
officials decided the agents would not
warn Flynn it was a crime to lie during
the FBI interview because they wanted
Flynn to be relaxed and they were
concerned that giving the warnings might
adversely affect their rapport now is
that bad behavior by the agents unclear
right I mean the fact is that when
you're police officer and you're
interviewing a suspect you have to
inform them of their right to have an
attorney present if you have arrested
the
but if you're just bringing a witness in
in for questioning then you don't
actually have to warn them of the
possibility of lying to the police being
a crime right you just have to you you
just have to interview them so um that's
the the basic rule is that if you're not
in detention then you don't have a right
to an attorney
under under domestic United States law
this is sort of the same case so the FBI
doesn't have to warn Flynn that he can't
have an attorney President President or
that any statements he can that he says
can and will be used against him in a
court of law like you would I'm on or
Miranda warnings don't apply to this
particular situation that said does it
sound a little bit dishonest for the FBI
to have brought in Flynn under the
auspices of we're having a friendly
little conversation and then sandbag him
with false charges yeah especially when
you get him on something as minor as he
talked with the Russians in the middle
of the transition which is not in and of
itself criminal activity this is why a
lot of folks are upset today again I
think the upset is a little bit
overwrought but I understand why folks
think that this the same thing would not
have been done to any Obama officials
for example now meanwhile there was a
terrorist attack in France another one
and it did not make global headlines in
the same way that that terrorist attacks
have in the past the reason being that
we are getting used to this
unfortunately according to the Daily
Mail at least three people were killed
13 others injured when a gunman opened
fire at a Christmas market in Strasbourg
northeastern France on Tuesday evening
police identified the gunman as sheriff
check at a Strasburg Bourne 29 year olds
has a criminal record and is a
designated threat to the state on the
security services watchlist a manhunt is
now underway for a cat who managed to
flee the scene in a hijacked taxi after
being wounded in a shootout with
soldiers and President Emmanuel macron
has raised Frances terror level the
carnage unfolded just after 8:00 p.m.
local time outside the historic
Christmas market in Strasbourg Central
Square + Kleber one of the busiest areas
in the city which is also home to the
European Parliament four of the people
injured were still fighting for their
lives six others seriously hurt
witnesses described one of the victims
as a South as a male South East Asian
tourists who had been shot in the head
the guy apparently was on the terror
watchlist
so this person was known to police I
don't know why the Europeans have this
terror watchlist where apparently you
only appear after you've committed an
act of terror and then we apparently
worried about it he was on the terror
watch list and apparently well he was
shooting he said the magic words he said
i'll who akbar while he was shooting
motives still unknown so that's always
exciting is when you hear that somebody
shouts Allahu Akbar while shooting
people and we still have motive unknown
so the source police source said
security forces had opened fire in an
area of the city where the suspect was
thought to be hiding the source did not
give the address it was unclear if the
shooter had been located so good stuff
yeah again another radical Islamist
terrorist attack in the heart of Europe
and yet you're considered Islamophobic
if you wonder whether immigration to
Europe ought to be vetted or curbed if
you do that then you have a problem
instead we're all supposed to sort of
plunge our heads into the sand and
pretend that nothing threatening has
ever happened because of mass Islamic
immigration into Europe which is of
course silly and that's not to say the
vast majority of people who are coming
into Europe are criminals or terrorists
they're not but if you're not vetting
the folks coming into your country then
it should not be a surprise when some of
those people turn out to be bad people
terrorists threats to public security
now meanwhile Google showed up on the
hill for a hearing yesterday
and whenever tech companies show up on
the hill for hearings about how they run
their business it gets really awkward
because nobody in Congress is below the
age of 97 except for Alexander Ocasio
Cortez who is 29 and knows nothing but
everybody else in Congress isn't there's
a huge age gap it's basically or 97 or
you're 29 and know nothing so there's no
point at which people actually know
things in Congress
all these 97 year olds were grilling the
heads of Google on the biasing of Google
results and they clearly do not know
what they are talking about like over
and over and over they were just saying
silly things so for example Steve Cohen
who is a democratic representative from
Tennessee here he was saying that he's
angry at Google because when he Google's
himself mean things come up in the
Google results like I put my name in
here Rep Steve Cohen that punched news
this weekend I was on MSNBC four times
and yet with first thing that comes up
is the Daily Caller not exactly a
liberal but I guess well-known group
dens roll called then Breitbart news in
the Memphis Business Journal then
Breitbart news then Breitbart so it
looks like you are overly using
conservative news organizations on your
news and I'd like you to look into over
use of conservative news organ
to put on liberal people's news on
Google okay maybe the only people who
don't wrap what Steve Cohen says are
people on the right because the left
basically ignores them
now Cohen was saying this because there
were folks on the right who are claiming
that Google was biased against
conservatives and a lot of its search
results now we heard The Daily wire know
that Google is biased against
conservatives in some of its search
results there was a while there where
the where Google had an app basically it
had it had a section of its website
where if you searched a Daily wire then
all the results from a left-wing
fact-checking organization came up on
the right side of the page and did the
same thing for the Daily Caller is it
the same thing for the Federalists it
did not do the same thing for any
left-wing website it did not fact check
any of their stories and show how
dishonest those websites were and by the
way over tailee where when we make
mistakes we make corrections to those
mistakes just as any other news
organization would but nobody in
Congress seems to understand exactly how
all of this works and so the members of
Congress simply suggest that Google is
absolutely neutral Google has no bias
whatsoever in a second we're going to
talk a little bit more about that and
why that simply is not true first let's
talk about your second Amendment right
so when the founders crafted the
Constitution the first thing they did
was to make sacred the rights of the
individual to share ideas without
limitation by the government the second
thing the founders did was make sure
that you could protect those rights in
armed fashion Bravo Company
manufacturing was started in a garage by
a marine vet more than two decades ago
to build a professional-grade product
that meets combat standards BCM believes
the same level of protection should be
provided to every American regardless of
whether they are a private citizen or a
professional BCM is not a sporting arms
company they designed the engineer and
they manufacture life-saving equipment
they assume that every rifle leaving
their shop will have to be used in a
life-or-death situation by a responsible
citizen or a law enforcement officer or
a soldier overseas I believe in the
Second Amendment not because I'm a
hunter I'm not I don't believe in the
Second Amendment because I like sport
shooting because I don't really have
time I believe in the Second Amendment
because I want to be able to protect
myself and my family and my values and
my country and that's what BCM believes
too every components of a BCM rifle is
hand assembled and tested by Americans
to a life-saving standard they feel a
moral responsibility to provide tools it
will not fail the user when it's not
just a paper target but God forbid
somebody coming to do harm to learn more
about Bravo Company manufacturing head
on over to Bravo Company MFG comm and
you can discover more about their
products special offers upcoming news
that's Bravo Company and FG comm if you
need more convincing go check them out
over at youtube.com slash Bravo Company
USA when you do then you can see all of
the all of the great products and
services they provide and also you can
see the cool guys who founded the
company it's really awesome
find out more about PCM again
youtube.com slash Bravo Company USA or
check them out of Bravo Company MFG comm
really they are a spectacular go check
them out right now okay well I do want
to talk more about Google's bias also a
piece in The Washington Post suggesting
that I should not actually speak at the
March for Life in a piece at Vox
suggesting that women have better sex
under socialism which is why women are
prostituting themselves as Venezuela I
suppose we'll get to all of that in just
a second first you're gonna have to go
subscribe over at daily where you get
the rest of the show live claims and
show live Michael Moses show live and
come January two more hours of me every
day behind the paywall
so if you love the show but you want
more you want more in-depth exploration
or things break later in the day you
want to check it out go check it out
right now
$9.99 a month $99 a year for all of
those aforementioned glories plus this
be very greatest and beverage vessels
look at this look at this massive piece
of vessel where it is just spectacular
in every the best the most beautiful
about unreal great go check it out right
now also please subscribe over at
YouTube and iTunes and you get access to
our Sunday special our latest Sunday
special features Bishop Robert Barron we
had a great conversation about theology
and faith I know a lot of faith-based
Sunday specials this month because come
on it's Advent so go check that out
right now here's a little bit of Bishop
Robert Barron this is Bishop Robert
Barron tune in this Sunday to the Ben
Shapiro Sunday special program we talked
about lots of interesting things from
God and religion society to morality I
think you'll find the conversation
really interesting it was a really
interesting conversation you're gonna
want to check that out this Sunday it's
really a lot of fun we have some great
Sunday specials coming up in the very
near future I mean great one so go
subscribe over to iTunes and YouTube
leave us a review we always appreciate
we are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so as I say there is bias at Google but
very few people on the hill actually
know enough about Google to understand
how the bias actually operates so for
example you have Democrats head Liu from
out here in California and he says that
the only reason there are bad search
results for people like Steve Scalise is
because Google is unbiased and because
Steve Scalise is a jerk so basically the
Google results are reflective of the
fact that there are a bunch of jerky
Republicans so if everything is biased
to the left it's not because there's
bias it's because Republicans are
terrible people if you want positive
search results do positive things if you
don't want negative search results don't
do negative things and just some of my
colleagues across Iowa if you're getting
bad press articles and bad search
results don't blame Google or Facebook
or Twitter consider blaming yourself
yeah except for the fact that that's not
exactly how Google and Facebook and
Twitter work now there's no individual
who's sitting behind the scenes and
manipulating the algorithms over at
Google that's not how any of this works
here is how it works so Eric Weinstein
who a friend of mine that a member of
the intellectual dark web probably in
all honesty its founder he's a guy who
is the the the business head of Peter
Thiel's Empire and Pierre Thiel of
course a major investor originally in
Facebook major in he was the creator of
PayPal nobody knows the internet better
than Eric doesn't mean Eric really knows
what he's talking about and here is what
he says his Google literally tells you
how they buy a serve you of the world
only they call it unbiased and unbiased
thing is supposedly politically neutral
it's just that in view of woke engineers
conservatives are typically biased by
history privilege biological
essentialism etc and so he says of
Google CEO sundar Pichai he says do you
unbiased these are questions we ask do
unbias searches you think are biased
under an internal fairness initiative
did Google find that history can
represent latency bias findings in
biology and psychology can lead to
exclusion bias economic theory can lead
to inequality bias etc so in other words
what he's saying is that Google biases
through its own biasing because if they
were just allowed to allow the full
stream of information to carry forth
then what would end up is maybe a bunch
of right-wing stuff that people are
interested in so instead they unbiased
the results to ensure that conservatives
are downplayed he says if you found
conservatives we're likely to believe in
more traditional interpretations of
gender biology markets military power
ethnicity
border psychology wealth achievement
would they be more likely to be unbiased
by Google that's how this works
I hope someone took a shot at this line
of questioning but I'm writing this as a
non-conservative because this no bias
game is moronic
we don't need fresh faces we need tough
folks in Congress with technical
backgrounds who can operate in all areas
where Google operates in other words
somebody has to set the parameters
somebody has to set the parameters for
all of this somebody has to set the
parameters for how these algorithms work
in the first place and how the unbiased
thing operates and Google is doing so in
biased fashion as Eric says and the fact
that folks in Congress don't really get
it is pretty astonishing by the way
there is some pretty solid evidence of
bias inside Google representative Matt
Katz of Florida he slammed the bias at
this hearing yesterday at Google I would
strongly suggest that one of the crisis
response tools that you use isn't an
investigation into the discourse of your
employees on resisting the trump
presidency resisting the Trump agenda
and then smothering some of the
conservative outlets that seem to
amplify that content okay and I think
Matt Katz is not completely wrong about
this now a piece of breaking news that I
didn't get to earlier breaking news is
that Michael Cohen has now been
sentenced to three years in prison for
campaign finance violations the idea
here is that he again was ordered to
commit these campaign violations at the
behest of President Trump as I said
earlier I think that that is a stretch
but Cohen is pleading guilty to crimes
that are friendly for the prosecutors
specifically so that he can get off on
on worse charges
you know the charges with regard to tax
fraud and taxi medallions and all of the
rest according to CNN Michael Cohen has
now been sentenced to three years in
prison president Trump's former lawyer
and fixer Michael Cohen said he takes
full responsibility for the actions he
has previously pled guilty to during his
appearance in a New York Federal Court
on Wednesday
Cohen is in court to be sentenced as
part of special counsel Robert Muller's
investigation into Russian meddling in
the 2016 election he says I take full
responsibility for each Act I pled
guilty to the personal ones to me and
those involving the President of the
United States of America in court
Wednesday morning Cohen's attorney
offered a sweeping case for leniency
comparing the significance of Khan's
actions and the work of the special
counsel to the Watergate investigation
he said the cooperation here should be
viewed against a non-standard framework
the special counsel's office
investigation is of utmost national
significance no less than scene 40
years ago in Watergate so therefore he
should be let off because they're going
after the president now again critics of
the prosecution here are going to say
that Cohen didn't actually commit a
campaign finance crime even if he did
commit a campaign finance crime it now
has to be established that he did so at
the behest of President Trump and that
Michael Cohen is basically pleading
guilty because he was guilty of a bunch
of other ancillary crimes and that
therefore he is pleading guilty to these
ones specifically in order to get off on
other ones suffice it to say this is not
good news for the President of the
United States during his remarks Kohn
addressed the president's comment
referring to him as weak but said it was
for a much different reason reason Cohen
said quote recently the president
tweeted a statement calling me weak and
it was correct but for much different
reason than he was implying it was
because time and time again I felt it
was my duty to cover up his dirty deeds
he said his action stands in part this
is the the attorney for Cohen his action
stands a profound contrast to the
decision of some others not to cooperate
and allegedly to double deal while
pretending to cooperate in addition to
the disclosures from the US Attorney's
office in Manhattan about Trump's
participation in payments to silence
women Muller also supplied fresh
revelations on the President on Friday
disclosing new information on a set of
efforts to communicate between Trump his
associates in the Russian government
according to CNN they try to quote Cohen
as saying that he was meeting with
Russian government officials but again
none of that is necessarily illegal so
the net seems to be tightening around
president Trump here although again I
think there's a pretty solid case to say
that President Trump is not guilty of a
criminal enterprise there's no question
that within the next month there's gonna
be serious talk in democratic circles
about whether to move forward with
impeachment of President Trump and this
is going to bring up a lot of questions
about whether President Clinton should
have been impeached shoes impeached for
obstruction of justice and perjury
there's not convicted in the Senate on
either of those charges but he was
impeached on that basis and if President
Trump is to be gotten on any basis it
will be on very similar auspices to how
President Clinton was impeached in 1999
he was actually impeached in 98 and then
he was acquitted by the Senate in 1999
so in just a second I don't get to the
dumbest stories of the day I also want
to get to the new 20/20 frontrunner so
there's a poll out yesterday and it
suggests his moveon.org poll pull of
progressive leftists and NBC News
reported that the straw poll of
moveon.org members unscientific poll but
still
kind of relevant they are now favoring
these progressive leftists Texas Senate
candidate better or Roarke over Joe
Biden so their number one choice is bata
or work Robert O'Rourke some twenty nine
percent respondent said they didn't know
who they wanted but Rourke has has
seized a narrow lead with 15.6 percent
of respondents followed by former Vice
President Joe Biden at fourteen point
nine percent and senator Bernie Sanders
at thirteen point one percent
Elizabeth Warren way down in the pack
Warren looks like she's lived past her
sell-by date
and the same thing is true Bernie
Sanders it looks like Bernie Sanders has
lost a lot of the enthusiasm that
carried him forward in 2016 when the
moveon.org crowd they're all Bernie Bros
now it looks like they're gonna be bado
bros but bado is the most dangerous
candidate in the Democratic field he's
the person who you have to look out for
the press loves the guy and there are
three basic pillars of the Democratic
Party at this point the intersectional
coalition all of these various pandered
to minority groups that are essentially
being told by the Democratic politicians
that they ought to be privileged in
American society because of a past
history of victimization well rock
panders to those people he Penner's to
those people by by suggesting I'm not
when I say those people I don't mean
actual members of minority groups I mean
that he is pandering to politically
active progressive leaders who consider
themselves part of this intersectional
coalition he is he's pandering to a lot
of those folks specifically because by
saying things like the criminal justice
system is inherently biased and racist
this sort of stuff you have to say if
you actually want to succeed with the
intersectional coalition he also has to
appeal to the mains mainline Democrats
and yes to appeal to the progressive
move on.org is the Bernie Sanders wing
of the party they like beta the
intersectional coalition likes bado
the mainstream Democratic Party likes
bado because O'Rourke is smart enough
that he was never a member of the
Congressional Progressive the
Congressional Progressive Caucus instead
he joined the New Democrat coalition
which was a centrist caucus with
Clintonian views according to Social
Democratic columnist Elizabeth breunig
he's been rather mild on climate change
issues at least for the radical left but
of course he's being upheld by the media
I think that at this point overwork
would be a fool not to run for president
he still got bank from from his last
election cycle and he's got a lot of
momentum and people are looking for a
fresh face he is young the media love
him and he is also
combative so you know he's a dangerous
candidate and pretending that he is
going to simply fade away into the
horizon I don't think is accurate in any
way now meanwhile the stupidest stories
of the day there is a piece in The
Washington Post today about me
headlining the March for Life there's a
piece by a guy named Charles Camozzi who
is the head of Democrats for life which
means he's the only member of Democrats
for life because they're like three
Democrats for life now again I think
there are a lot of people who vote
Democrat who may be pro-life I can't
imagine why maybe they found the one
representative who is somewhat pro-life
in the Democratic Party but the
Democratic Party as a whole is a
pro-abortion party there's no question
about this they're radically
pro-abortion
in every available case they are
radically pro-abortion but this guy
Charles Como's he says I should not
speak at the March for life I'm
keynoting the March for Life in early
January very much looking forward to it
he says that in a few he says the
biggest problem with the March for Life
has to do with the near total lack of
huge name promoters as the anti-abortion
movement continues to be the third rail
for American celebrities that's about to
change in a few weeks the March will be
noted by a genuine superstar Ben Shapiro
well thank you the 34 year old Orthodox
Jew from Southern California hosts the
most popular conservative podcast in the
country a pre-election special he did
this fall was one of the most watched
shows on cable TV the day it aired his
daily where opinion news website post
140 million pageviews per month per
month and this guy says that many of the
pro-life movement will consider this a
huge get not me despite Shapiro's star
power and stature I consider his
appearance a serious mistake for the
March 1 that will move us even further
from being understood as a broad-based
human rights movement we need to embody
in order to go from fringe to mainstream
the idea being that I am a partisan
Republican or a conservative and open
conservative and therefore it's bad for
me to speak at the March for Life so
this is what he says his Trump is a
buffoon but Shapiro is helping to form
the imagination of many millions of
young conservatives he also has deep
relationships and regular exchanges with
pro-choice members of the intellectual
dark web and is one of the few pro-life
public figures who has taken seriously
outside the pro-life movement itself
though I disagree with Shapiro about 60
to 70 percent of the time I listen to
his entertaining show regularly and
consider him a very important voice for
vulnerable populations his commitment to
argument and evidence represents the
only chance those who lack power in our
culture have to get their interest taken
seriously so what's the problem the
problem is that I'm going to be doing
the podcast live and that because the
podcast is politically oriented this is
going to alienate Democrats honestly if
you're more
by my Republican politics then you are
by the pro-choice movement or if you
feel that I can't be a good promoter of
pro-life beliefs that if you believe I
can't be a good promoter of pro-life
beliefs because I am conservative then I
would suggest that you're making a very
large mistake when folks on the Left say
something that is right it is my job to
give them credit for saying something
that is right and when I say something
that is pro-life and correct seems to me
pro-life democrats should be on my side
and it's not my job to pretend that the
democratic party has played an innocuous
role in in the pro-choice versus
pro-life debate okay let's get to some
things that I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like that I
have to show you this this is so I will
acknowledge I love magic I don't just
mean I'm not talking bout like Harry
Potter I'm talking about the the kind of
sleight of hand magic illusion Michael
illusion III love this stuff so one of
my favorite places on earth for example
in Los Angeles is the Magic Castle the
Magic Castle is just spectacular if you
ever get a chance to go there you get an
invite it's just the best it's great I
took my wife there the other night it's
a great date place so Magic Castle gets
a promotion Magic Castle is awesome and
it's pretty exclusive and you have to
dress real nice I remember one time I
went to Magic Castle that the dress code
at Magic Castle is that you have to wear
Crucible pants have to wear like nice
suit pants and jacket I was wearing a
nice pair of khakis and a jacket but my
khakis were not creasing Bowl they made
me borrow a pair of pants from the
backroom so I spent the night walking
around in somebody else's pants which
was real awkward but in any case that's
beside the point
I have to show you this magic trick okay
so this is this magic routine is the
best magic routine I have ever seen it's
by a guy named Eric Chen he just won a
international magic competition for a
close-up magic I love this is my
favorite kind of magic so I'm not big
into the sawing a woman in half making
making an airplane disappear that kind
of stuff because once you learn how the
trick is done you know how the trick is
done but with sleight of hand you know
exactly how they're doing the trick and
you still can't catch them it's really
amazing so here is this guy Eric Chen
uses a Chinese citizen I believe and
this is legitimately the best magic I
have ever seen in my entire life
so for folks who can't see what he's
doing he is turning cards into coins
it's truly incredible so now he's
scooping coins into a box and then he is
going to close the box open the box
again
he's just making things disappear right
and left he just turned his vest from
blue and red back to black I mean it's
just amazing go and watch the whole
routine if you can find you can find it
on YouTube that has several million hits
but it is it is just spectacular did you
guys watch it backstage I mean if you
haven't then it's it's unbelievable
okay other things that I like so a sad
end for a woman who was married to a 300
year old ghost pirate a very Santa and
this is the original announcement the
beautiful I think announcement that she
was going to marry a 300 year old ghost
pirate a few years ago but now she has
apparently left the marriage her was her
original statement announcing her
engagement to the ghost pirate married
to a 300 year old ghost pirate I'm the
first person in the UK and Ireland to
marry and posthumously she says when
deceased pirate John Teague contacted
her spiritually she had some doubts but
he proved himself by telling her
historic facts
she later googled and found to be true
amanda says she seemed John and Astro
travel and in meditation the two were
married on international waters
surrounded by a small group of friends
and family everyone in high spirit
love is love guys love his love hashtag
I mean I don't know why you would think
this is stupid or anything if this is if
first of all if she believes that the
ghost pirate speaks to her and that she
can marry the ghost pirate I don't see
why you would think that is a delusional
there's nothing delusional about that it
doesn't impede her capacity to function
in normal society seems totally fine to
me and as far as her choice of partner
how dare you discriminate against a
woman marrying a ghost how dare you I
mean maybe Casper's on her list too but
it's this was very exciting well this
was very sad because she broke up with
the ghost pirate
he must have ghost in her he at a
certain point he just decided he was no
longer his boo and as much as Matt Walsh
correctly stated it was sad because they
really thought there were soulmate e's
so very very sad stuff Amanda Sparrow
Sparrow Teague wrote on social media
changed her name to a dead pirates name
yeah this is a healthy person she wrote
I feel it's time to let everyone know my
marriage is over I guess that she found
it unsatisfying for some reason she said
I will explain all in due course but for
now all I want to say is be very careful
when dabbling in spirituality it's not
something to mess with well I guess you
know when you mess around with ghosts
then your aura ends up slimed very very
weird stuff sup that stuff he said
growing up in Ireland in my ear you were
taught that if a man bedded you he
should Wed you I knew for my research
that spiritual marriage was a thing so
is more than it was more me that wanted
to get married than him he would have
been happy like most men with just sex
because she says that apparently she was
having sex with her ghost partner she
the apparition began on a happier note
in 2014 when she says she suddenly felt
these spirits energy with her in bed she
told the daily started the spirits out
with her while she watched TV and drove
her car and then she started developing
strong feelings toward it alright it's
worth noting that in the Pirates of the
Caribbean franchise by the way the
character of Edward Teague was played by
Keith Richards and is the father of Jack
Sparrow so presumably his his actual
full name Jack Sparrow would be Jack
Teague so she just has a I guess that
she just really likes Johnny Depp a lot
like Fay Johnny Depp so a sad a sad end
to a meaningful relationship and I guess
that you know we should all moor and I
mean let's let's be real about this when
someone's heart breaks over marrying a
three hundred fake ghost and they have
to break up and then when all of your
hopes and dreams just sort of disappear
for no reason then you have to you have
to wonder whether whether life can go on
as it did before
you know what happens under the bedsheet
stays under the bedsheet okay meanwhile
other things that so let's do a couple
of things that I hate
thing number one that I ate Sean illing
who is actually a nice guy right over at
voxcom which as I say very often is a
repository of extreme stupidity
Sean illing has an interview with woman
named Kristin Godsey and it is titled
why women have better sex under
socialism according to an anthropologist
yes I am sure women had better sex well
is it the tyrannical domination that
they really like or is the forced
redistribution of income according to a
new book by Christian Godsey an
anthropologist at the University of
Pennsylvania she argues that women have
better sex under socialism if that
sounds strange to you consider this a
survey of East and West Germans after
reunification in 1990 found that Eastern
women the socialist side of Germany
during the Cold War has twice as many
orgasms as Western women what in the
world accounts for such a wide gap
according to Godsey it's about social
safety nets if she argues you build a
society that supports women and doesn't
punish them for having children or
devalue their labor it turns out they'll
be happier and have better sex except
for how that is a lie except for how all
the people in the West in Europe at the
time this was happening we're living in
democratic socialist states with
extraordinarily strong safety nets and a
serious focus on gender inequity maybe
maybe it's because marital rates were
actually higher in places like the
Soviet Union than they were outside
places like the Soviet Union because it
turns out that inside the Soviet Union
marriage out of wedlock was actually not
something that these empires really
liked a whole hell of a lot the line
between social safety nets and better
sex is blurrier than the title of the
book implies says Sean LA meaning it
doesn't exist but there are some
interesting ideas here and to her credit
gods he doesn't reduce everything to a
simplistic choice between capitalism and
socialism nor does she call for a turn
to soviet-style communism her book is
really about using socialist principles
to offset the gender inequities in
capitalist societies again I I think
that if you really believe that women in
the Soviet Union were having a better
sex because they were in the Soviet
Union it's worked out great in Venezuela
obviously working out everywhere I mean
using the Soviet Union is the example
you would figure that if you're gonna
write this book you'd Eliseo women in
Norway are having better sex right that
isn't Norway the new hot socialist
country even though it's not really
socialist but using the Soviet Union
means I get to use Venezuela and Cuba's
examples so if you're now using the
Soviet Union as a place for great sex
house comedy China working out how about
Venezuela you think women are happier in
these places I think not in Venezuela
unless there have eaten the eaten stray
dogs and then getting down I'm having a
feeling not so great over there also
these are all self reporting surveys it
turns out that self reporting surveys in
the Soviet Union may not reflect reality
who would have thought okay so there's
that meanwhile another thing that I hate
today there's a there's a guy whose name
is Chad Felix green he's a conservative
and you were a piece for The Federalist
talked about talking about being gay he
says the stigma against my conservative
politics is worse than the stigma being
gay meaning that he has treated worse
online for being conservative than for
being homosexual well there's a piece
today by a woman named Maureen Thiessen
called conservative gays need to shut
the F up so proving Chad Felix green's
thesis that it is worse to be a
conservative than to be gay in social
media she says that's good news right I
mean in a utopian society nobody would
much care whether people prefer to F or
fall in love with but everyone would
care deeply about the laws and policies
that would actually impact the world
so our hypothetical utopian folks
wouldn't bat an eye at two men sharing a
kiss but would likely get pretty pissed
if someone came around advocating the
use of tear gas against people in need
or death for sick people who don't have
the money to pay for treatment or
killing machines for everybody so in
other words it's good it's good that
Chad
Felix Green feels more discriminated
against for his conservatism than for
his than for his homosexuality it's a
good thing so at least they're owning it
at least folks on the Left are now
owning the fact that they're
discriminatory and terrible so that's
exciting stuff okay the final thing that
I hate today we're going to do a piece
of deconstructing the culture so we
haven't deconstructed the culture in a
while when we deconstruct the culture we
take a piece of popular culture and we
look at the messaging in that piece of
popular culture that you may not have
been listening to because very often
when they play a song on the radio you
may not catch the lyrics you may not be
seeing the music video
well our intrepid producer Sonya sent me
a piece that she got from the Google's
about the ten hottest music videos of
2018 suffice it to say replete with
stupidity and I had to stop when I saw
Janelle monáe's pink spelled P y NK
because we can't spell things correctly
anymore because that's uncool
Janome a is the feminist of the day she
is a feminist Nouveau she is bisexual
and she says that feminism is all about
the female genitalia now I have to
acknowledge that it used to be
I love that we live in a society where
the subtlety of baby it's cold outside
which is basically how a lot of wooing
goes on right I mean any every woman
every man who is honest about this knows
that when you are wooing a person of the
opposite sex particularly a man willing
a woman very often it is the woman who
is saying I need to leave now and the
guy saying why don't you just stick
around a little bit longer that's not
rapey
okay rapey is when you actually raped
somebody it is not rapey to say - stick
around the girl want is is divided on
whether she wants to go home whether if
she wants to stay and then she decides
you know what I'm gonna stay right
that's that's not raping that is her
making a free-will decision but that's
really bad we got a ban baby it's cold
outside but real feminism real feminism
is not a woman making a decision to stay
with a man real feminism is talking
about the actual biology of the vagina
that's real feminism real feminism is
dressing up in costumes that mimic the
labia that's real feminism so here's
Janelle Monae in pink I will describe
this as best I can without going blue
here and I will tell you the lyrics to
this really I think fulfilling and and
embolden and empowering piece of art
from Janelle Monae to explain how
terrible this video is wait oh my
goodness okay so this video is so
insanely obscene basically Janelle Monae
we can pause it Janome annai is dressed
in a pair of pants that look like labia
I mean that's that's what it is designed
to look like so she's obviously
describing the vagina and the clitoris
had a certain point here and the idea is
that it is empowering to talk about your
genitalia ad nauseam the actual lyrics
are pink like the inside of your blank
and we're supposed to know that means
genitalia baby pink behind all of the
doors crazy pink like the tongue that
goes down obviously a reference to oral
sex maybe pink like the paradise found
okay this stuff
is rated ax right I mean these are rated
X lyrics but this is this this thing by
the way earned a Grammy nomination on
Friday for best music video for this
song because true art is dressing up on
a beach wearing weird pants that look
like the female anatomy and this is from
her dirty computer album just wonderful
stuff now do women really feel empowered
by talking about their vajayjays just
just a question like I've always found
it really off-putting when guys talk
about their junk I I find it not
empowering at all it's not gentlemanly
it's not good it's a piece of your
anatomy do you spend all your day
talking about your thumb like it's
something that is just there so so the
fact that you're talking about it ad
nauseam is really ridiculous and the
idea that women think of well you know
what it makes me more empowered when
society accepts that I have a vagina
right but number one I've learned that
the vagina can be very male that's what
I have learned from the left is that
just because you're a vagina it doesn't
make you a female obviously so I don't
know why it's empowering to females to
talk about the female anatomy it's not
female anatomy it's just anatomy and
it's sometimes associated with the
social construction that is femininity
that's what I've learned from from folks
on the left so they shouldn't be
empowering to women at all in fact it's
cisgender to assume that this is
empowering to women it's empowering to
all people whether they identify as
women or men many men have vaginas I
have been reliably informed by the
scientific community so there's that
then even if you assume you put aside
that idiocy and assume that there is in
fact a correlation between the female
anatomy and being female I don't
understand why that would be the thing
that you choose to take pride and it
seems to me that females have been
making the case for a while that they
are more than their Anatomy that
femininity involves more than just your
genitalia and that men if they think of
you as just your genitalia that's a bad
thing that's no be objectifying you
which I agree with that if you want to
treat a woman as a full-fledged human
being you probably should not be
thinking quite so much about her
genitalia and start thinking about the
folds of her brain inside or you should
start thinking about the things she
thinks and feels and the actions she
takes in her life if I were to talk
about all the wonderful things that make
my wife my wife genitalia like this is a
component part but this is not what
makes my wife my wife like every woman
on planet earth has female anatomy okay
all of them but what makes my wife my
wife what makes her special and what
makes
unique as a woman is not that what makes
her unique as a woman is the fact that
she's a wonderful wife the fact she's a
wonderful mother the fact that she is a
doctor the fact that she does all of
these wonderful things every day that's
what makes her unique person and so I
respect my wife as a human but you can't
have it both ways if you're armed the
feminist left and you want to reduce
females to their genitalia but then say
also the genitalia don't mean that you
are female and also men should stop
objectifying your genitalia and also if
you talk about female genitalia then
this makes you a sexist none of these
things can hold true at the same time
but if this is the empower if this is
the new empowerment we got a ban baby
cult baby it's cold outside but talking
in graphic terms about the appearance of
female genitalia that's empowerment man
what a world you have created you morons
okay we'll be back here tomorrow to talk
more about our Murano quarrel I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing